would you ever say to like um somebody
out of left field let's write a song
together i thought the lou reed thing
was a great experiment on your guy's
part
i mean lou reed who's better than
[ __ ] lou reed i mean you know he's
the coolest
and it was right in this room right
where we are here lou stood right we're
basically
in between james and kirk and it was it
was an incredible summer
eight eight nine years ago and the
memories of that
i'll always treasure and i know
everybody in the band has
of you know fond memories of that time
it was uh
incredible wouldn't change a thing and
the fact that it's sort of
kind of pissed more straight
you know square metal dudes off a little
bit i think is good to always uh
[ __ ] with the perceptions a little bit i
always heard that he was um
the angriest [ __ ] on the planet
like like it
made you guys look calm you know what i
mean yeah i think it was just
i mean it was a it was a protective
shield man
so many of those dudes in the 60s and
70s just got [ __ ] over by their
managers by the agents by the record
companies i mean he was even with us
a little bit that we met him out in new
york we were doing that show at madison
square garden and
it took a little while uh but once the
eyes broke in the rehearsal room
and he knew he could sense that he was
safe with us uh
he totally let his guard down and then
he was the sweetest man
really and yeah i think we all in some
way kind of became protective
over him right definitely absolutely it
was really
really funny because uh when we were in
here jamming
you know he had a it had his own kind of
set of rules right
and so when we were playing some song i
stepped on the wall pedal
and he instantly ran up to the
microphone and said no
looked at him he goes no wall pedal no
guitar solos
no i was like why why would a guy
why would a creative have nose i mean
what if the wah pedal really [ __ ]
works that's like my parents won't get a
computer you know
exactly okay so this is what happened
right he said no guitar solos all right
so
one song i i thought oh we need a guitar
solo
so i had to write lou a letter i had to
send him
a letter and i had to wait and wait and
wait for his reply he never replied
i saw him the next day at rehearsal and
he said oh i got your email
by the way and that was it that was the
only reply back
but what was lou's point of view like i
think he just he would show up with
certain beliefs aesthetics
or whatever and it was a time of
experiment and it was a time
of of trying new things and say let's
try this let's try that we'd be out here
kind of on you know just feeling our way
through something
and then uh you would go in and listen
to it in the control room in there and
lou would be like
okay that's great that's a take and
we're like we haven't even
played it yet
i'm not saying that again
you